All right guys, so in this chapter, I'm going to be teaching you the one RCRD, all right.
So previously, I talked about four RCRDs, right.
So you would market the high and low of the four-hour candle.
But this one is on one our time from, and not every single one R candle is going to present
you a CRT trade.
Only at a very specific time, you will get a one RCRD candle.
And that is eight M.
So you wait for the eight M candle to close on the one R time frame, and then you are simply
marking out the high and the low of that candle, okay.
So afterwards, what you're doing is you're dropping down to one minute time frame, okay.
We are not dropping down to 15 minute or five minute, we're straight up going into one minute
time frame.
And then we're waiting for price to either take out the one R low or one R high.
Once we have taken that out, we are waiting for some form of confirmation.
So whether it's changing the state of delivery, which happens right here or a market structure
shift.
So right here, we got a market structure shift, right.
And we also have this Fair Valley gap around here.
So the next step would be to simply take our entry from this zone.
Now make sure that you keep an eye on the 930 AM news, high impact news.
So if there's a high impact news at 930, you have to avoid trading because you always want
to be trading afterwards after 15 minutes at least, right.
So you could probably take your trade at 945 if the news is over at 930, right.
So the news will happen at 930, you wait for price to settle down, give it like 15 minutes,
and then you can take your trade.
If the targets are hit, then you will not take that trade because the trade becomes
invalid.
If the high is taken out, if both the high and the low are taken out, if that makes
sense.
So this would be your entry.
And if I play this through, you can see that the take profit was hit now, a key thumb.
The key rule here is to use a firm from the CRT low to CRD high.
And at the 50% of the range, you are basically taking one partial and then you are going
break even, all right.
Or simply, you could just go break even at one to one wrist to the right ratio.
But the best approach is going break even at 0.5 level and taking one partial here,
going break even and then letting the trade run until the CRD high is taken out.
Let me give you guys more examples.
All right guys, so here is another example.
You can see we have the 8M candle.
So I'm going to simply mark out the high and the low of this candle.
Okay, very simple.
Then what I'm doing is I'm dropping down to one of them before I do that.
If the 9M candle, so this is the 8M candle, if the 9M candle opens and then it goes up
ahead and sweeps the 8M high and also sweeps some form of liquidity, then that makes it
a high probability CRD, one hour CRD, all right.
So I'm going to explain what I mean by that in a minute.
So let's go to the one minute.
We have the high and the low and you can see we take out the CRD high.
So now we are waiting for a market structure shift with displacement and that what happens
here.
We broke the structure and we also broke the structure.
Then we have this fair value gap.
This would be your entry.
Stop right above the high and our TP would be somewhere around here.
So we got a tap and the take profit was hit.
Extremely beautiful trade.
So what I mean by that, if I go to one hour time for him, you can see that the, let me
just remove this.
So this is the 8M high, 8M low.
The 9M candle, when it's swept liquidity, it's swept this high over here, right?
After it's swept this high, we got a one minute market structure shift and that made it a
high probability.
So you can see how the price displaced, right?
And one key thing to note there, if there's some form of like equal lows or equal highs
as a target, then that also makes it high probability.
Other guys, it's everything is based on liquidity and drawn liquidity, right?
Sweep of liquidity and then draw on liquidity, if that makes sense.
Let's move on to the next example.
All right guys, so here is another example, the 8M candle, just mark out the high and the
low of that candle.
Notice to the left, we have this PDA, right?
This is an auto block.
Surprise is currently in this auto block that makes it a high probability CRT, right?
So now I'm just going to go to the one minute chart and you can also go to the two minute
chart if you really want to look for very, very high probability market structure shifts.
But I like to stick on the one minute for this model.
So we took out the high, but we failed to close below this low.
And for this strategy, it is crucial that the body closes below it, okay?
But then price went up ahead, tapped into, I believe, the 50% of that auto block that
I showed you previously, and then we got a market structure shift.
So now if you look at it here, we have this tiny bit of fair value gap resting around
this level, right?
So what happens next?
It's very clear.
You can see we got tapped into this fair value gap.
The bodies were respected and then you can see price went up ahead and also swept the
liquidity that was formed inside the fair value gap.
So if you are, if you have been watching my YouTube videos, you must have an idea about
what I'm talking about here, why this liquidity was swept.
There is a course video as well from our previous, but if you don't know about this, you need
to really watch my videos in detail, because the liquidity that forms inside the fair
value gaps are very high probability liquidity, and they are going to be swept in some time.
And that happened right there.
So anyways, price went into this fair value gap, and then we had a beautiful push delivery
to the downside.
Very beautiful.
So let's move on to the next example, oops.
Alright guys, so here is the final example, and this is the ATM candle, and look at where
the price is at, around here, right?
And look at what happened at the 9M candle.
We tapped into the 0.5 level of this autoblock, and we also swept the 8M candle high.
So let's go back, right, when I marked out the 8M candle high and 8M candle low, then
I'm simply dropping down to one minute shot, and I'm waiting for price to take out that
high.
We got the high taken out, this is my market structure shift level.
We got it successfully right here, the body closed.
We have this autoblock, price tapped into the autoblock, filled this fair value gap.
So it tapped into this BPR, right here.
And you can see that the take profit was hit.
So I like to keep things mechanical, guys.
I really don't want you to be over-analyzing stuff.
This is, you can literally make a living with this simple model, the 8M candle.
Who would know that this is trading is very simple.
Who would know that trading was this simple, right?
Well anyways, this should be it for the first part of the course.
There will be more videos in the future.
I will be teaching you volume trading as well in this course, in the upcoming chapters
that will be coming in the future.
But I do not want to overdose you with so many concepts and educational content.
So that would be it.
Thank you so much for purchasing the course and watching it.
I really do hope that you get funded with the models that are provided to you.
And with practice, I promise you, you're going to achieve that.
And always, goodbye for now.